good morning guys good morning my bear
good morning good morning Mama good
morning good morning Mr taika
because we're going on a little bikini
family trip today I'm really excited
because today we're looking at our very
first rental so you know when you guys
watch the other video where we talked
about how we came up pretty good on our
first Vegas house like it's been part of
the plan
use the money earned there like not the
ball out which it's really hard to
resist because you know I like a lot of
toys and watches and stuff but the goal
is to really try to set ourselves up as
financially as possible so right now
it's a great time to get a pad because
of because of the interest rate it's
made it more of a buyer's market so a
lot of the home prices are coming down
and I saw a really CUNY house like it
really reminds me of our first house in
Monterey Park remember that one yeah so
it's like a really CUNY starter home in
a really good neighborhood it's also a
master planning Community it's not in
Summerlin but
um it is also a master plan Community
it's still in Vegas and I feel like this
would have been like one of a perfect
home for us at that time so I just want
to be able to provide that for people
that are looking for a similar home and
I believe we're getting we might build a
good good deal on it and sort of go
check it out
okay look at this CUNY little community
this is a reminder of our old Monterey
Park Community a little bit no this
isn't way better not really yeah our
other one was so new like the trees were
all like bare and like this looks weird
oh yeah it feels more settled yeah I
lived in and it just feels like a cool
Community look at that oh the b-roll
life I love seeing people with their
dogs that's cutie pie
had to make a left turn yeah yep look at
that everything nice and orderly super
clean oh man my Bears cars right there
that's a sign
that's one that's the car that Marvin
wants to get next the sick Defender oh
it's Christina
what she got it yeah oh play a player
yeah yeah
day Christina with the new Range Rover
play a player
did you know that uh Jill is gonna get
one oh really yeah yeah okay yeah she
was gonna get one
um but we end up getting this car
because because then this one we just
bought it cash but our goal is to um you
know like build more Financial Freedom
so we didn't want to have payments yet
oh yeah and if we're gonna get more
loans we wanted to like bring our debt
to income ratio lower and then so we're
like okay let's pay off our truck pay
this off and then we have zero death are
you okay hey remember remember Christina
yep and that's my mom
[Music]
Christina my mom's uh Lillian
all right so this is like one of Geo's
dreams car and not only did she get the
defender she got the extended version
which is freaking six I was like I gotta
take a look at the inside of this
Defender whoa
Bruh Bruh whoa look at that there's
little boots there's a nice car
wow this car is nice
this is awesome
that is beautiful
bro the defender you know I'm saying
play player
damn
all right so this is really cozy very
CUNY
very quaint very communal I could
totally see if you have like young
families living here and you have all
the kids that like get to know each
other they know like all the neighbors
Christmas decoration is a good sign
but that's the house right there what I
like about that already is they already
have a little balcony in the front so
you could like talk to the other people
is very CUNY all right when you first
come in my first impression is that it's
very CUNY I really like it it reminds me
of the Monterey Park home so much where
it's like open concept you got a cool
little living room right here you got
your kitchen which is almost like the
center piece of the house so while
you're cooking you can talk to the
people over here talk to the people over
here and then we have uh I believe like
a coat closet
right here which is really cool
and you walk over here
and you have a pretty big garage which I
like
so
usually like these starter homes the
garage are kind of small like in
Monterey Park got a pretty small one
this one it's like high ceiling you see
that because it's uh there's a step up
right here and then it's a car and a
half so you can see the lines so not
only can you park your cars like a lot
of these modern homes they make it where
you can have lots of storage space
because storage is usually issued these
days because everyone has so much stuff
now so the older homes that are built
for like 20
I'm not sure maybe even like
2010 and before they're still built with
like the old family structure in mind so
they don't have that much space for
storage but all the newer homes they
have a lot of storage space and I also
like this a place to right when you come
in dunk your keys and you don't have to
buy a piece of furniture it's already
built in here storage with your shoes
whatever way we've got the little
bathroom downstairs bathroom and then
time to follow taika upstairs
foreign
oh my goodness what's cool is you come
up to a loft which is super cutie and
cozy so if your kids get a little bit
bigger and need to have some separate
space like I think they're making it
like a little reading room
people can still like watch TV
downstairs while you have like a little
piece and quiet upstairs
this is the master
piece master bedroom and then you go
over here master bath so you got a
shower bathtub double sink super
convenient and a basement it's not a
basement
and then come in over this way
which is a lot of space there's a lot of
space and space is good because in
addition to not feeling cramped it
separates the sound
wow someone looks comfy
foreign
come over here you have the laundry room
on this side which is pretty big like
every room is well spaced I really like
it oh they turn this into like a study
like an office oh and this is the room
that goes to the balcony I was just
showing you guys that I really enjoy so
check it out
come right here
get some fresh air
feels good you can talk to your
neighbors hey put those back dude those
aren't even ours you have to talk to
your neighbors
look at the beautiful mountains oh man
this view is awesome
Jill's right this is way better than our
first house it's like our first home
um but cunia with better amenities
better views and you know what's crazy
I think it's almost half the price
that is what's crazy and it's more
square foot um I think our first home in
Monterey Park
I think was like 13 or 1500 square feet
similar layout but every single room a
little bit smaller we didn't have the
Loft upstairs this one's almost 2 000
square feet for almost half the price
it's crazy got a little guest room
probably unless they have kids
and uh here's the bathroom upstairs
so how do you like the house I think
I think perfect I think it's perfect for
like a little family
um because it has like the perfect
amount of space it's a perfect like
little starter
um no the location's really cool it
feels really safe it's really clean the
the current owner is really clean up the
property it's really clean yeah I really
like it cheese and I always want to get
things that I feel like that I would
have wanted yeah so that I can really
relate to like the property or
Investments and stuff and I felt like
this would have been a really cool home
yeah back in Monterey Park yeah no this
is great it's a it's a great property
okay I look at my mom over there
so this is a really interesting layout
I've never seen this before but I'm a
huge fan
so unlike normal houses like mine right
now where the garage door and the front
door on the same side in this community
all the garages on the back
but what I like about it is now you make
the front of the house a walking
community and in the back is where the
cars are going to drive so what's cool
about that is in between all the houses
where we saw how cozy it was people can
walk around without worrying about
getting like hit by a car or like
separating the type of vehicle traffic
you know so now if people want to just
drive in they don't have to worry about
people walking either besides my dumb
ass walking off the camera but that is a
really cool feature
I like it
oh man look at that view
it's beautiful
so to check out this neighborhood a
little bit more we decided to grab uh
some breakfast in the area just to kind
of get a better feel of the area and you
always know you're in a good place when
you have a baby Stacks in the area
probably haven't had baby Stacks in a
few months and uh the food's really good
here and I'm sure we can find something
from my mom because she's vegetarian so
I think go find something yummy for her
hey monkey do you miss baby snacks yeah
because there's one next to our house
and you always talk about that one
the the one next to our house oh yeah we
know we're at baby stats
what about baby Stacks right now you
know that it's not the same one but it's
the same food
what do you want to eat
what do you say pancakes red velvet yeah
because I know that's your favorite and
you love it from baby Stacks
yeah you like chocolate chip oh look at
that what's that sprinkle herb a
squiggly worm right there and
um
thank you
squiggly worm what did you just order
Mister
um
no but you order that yummy drink
Christmas drink
hot chocolate and you wanted one on top
oh you know the good stuff what no whip
like you whip
good job
that's that cookie butter French toast
got taika's little red velvet right
there
we got Mama a uh vegetarian omelette and
we got the spam and egg scramble with
the garlic rice that you have to get
when you come here it is insane uh just
like a little late for next week okay
can you please do the honors yeah that
garlic rice and that spam and that date
is up
oh man oh oh
man
oh yeah
oh dude look at that this is breakfast
of champions
oh my mom knows how to eat putting
ketchup on
damn player
dad play a player
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
let's try this you're gonna love it oh
yeah oh look at all those veggies in
there you got all the good stuff
yes
yes please
[Applause]
oh
yeah
what Santa sent you something it's not
for me what that's crazy bones I'm gonna
go open it in the living room that's
crazy I thought he's been a bad boy the
whole year me too but he's I guess he's
a good boy huh
oh that's so cute
that is so cute
so I think it says here you have to open
like that
elf
that is weird Okay
so I have to read you this book why is
this oh no you have to read him the book
do you know about the Elf on the Shelf
yeah yeah so
let me see real quick so I think I think
he like went in the box and then come to
our house oh
hey look that's
too yeah okay so
so right here it says I have to read
this book to you
but it says basically this guy is one of
Santa's helpers
he's an elf so and he makes twit for the
kids yeah he does but listen thank you
can you listen okay but it says right
here that you have to give him a name
yeah so we have to give him a name right
here
right here it says
uh we welcome our our Scout elf
by choosing a name what's his name
um
um go out
do I give him a different name just like
a name because his name's already l
oh uh
um he's a boy
um what's your name what's your name
what's your name
like a boy name
um but come on that's part one crazy
bones
20. yeah okay okay so this guy's name is
Connie okay okay and keep reading the
directions so
ready okay so this is what it says are
you paying attention to me yeah okay so
quanie are you paying attention to me so
quanie is Santa's elf right and he sent
his helper
so you can't touch him anymore
because he has magic oh so every night
when you go to sleep
he's gonna tell Santa if you've been
good or bad that's the way Santa knows
if you're a good or bad boy and then if
you're a good boy what does Santa do
yeah oh yeah but if you're a bad boy
what does Santa do no no presents so
he's gonna he's gonna watch you
how do you know that oh you're smart
dude
attract that boy yeah a lot of kids have
a bunch of them so tonight I'll read you
the book so that you know what's going
on or maybe I'll read you the book after
this and then we just have to leave them
alone but you can't touch them because
if you touch him he's gonna lose his
magic after this once he goes then he
does his thing I can't touch him either
nobody can touch him okay okay I won't
touch him so what's his name again
okay so quantity
the elf okay so we can't touch him
anymore okay so um I'm gonna read this
book and then we'll know what to do
so this is super Kini to be able to pass
on this CUNY
Christmas tradition I didn't really do
too many American Christmas traditions
so it's really cool to like
uh witness all of this but now I'm busy
give me a second
but now
I have a big huge task
ahead of me you see all this stuff
well that garage door
isn't
um our actual garage door
like right now worldwide there's an
international like supply chain shortage
and all that stuff right
so when we got the house
that garage door is actually a loner
because they can't give you a house
without a garage door because you got to
put your stuff in it but our actual
garage door the ones that are pretty
freaking dope they're coming tomorrow
and they said for them to install it
your garage has to be empty and we're
like oh my God so
I have to clean all this stuff out
meanwhile also sort through things so
I'm gonna try to clean and sort at the
same time but I'm really excited because
the garage doors are freaking sick like
this one looks I mean it's plain and it
works but it doesn't match the STEEZ of
the house you know what I'm saying and
even with like um you know the fridge
that you guys saw in our kitchen that's
a loaner fridge too like we actually
have a pretty dope Ridge and it's right
here and it's both of those boxes but we
just need pieces for them to install it
so this is what the garage door looks
like right now
this is just flat like white like that
and uh
I can't wait to show you guys tomorrow
what the garage door looks like but I
have a big task in front of me because I
gotta
empty all of this out and probably just
like put it right there and hopefully it
doesn't rain
all right guys I was trying to move fast
trying to race against the sun because
it is dark now
and I think I did a little bit of damage
so look at the inside
uh we're able to
um I move those two big ass ridges over
oh my God no why why
don't talk to me right now I'm in the
middle of vlogging
uh now I have allergies oh my God what
the heck is going on I need to get my
life together anyways move that fridge
over remember that was over there and
then that allowed me to put this toolbox
there once I clip this toolbox
two bucks toolbox I had all this area
that I can start moving stuff in so I
put all my ammo in there now so I have
all my tactical gear and tools here
got some of my dad stuff or IP in here I
didn't want to keep that stuff out
um outside because a lot of it is like
like sentimental and like memorable type
stuff so
I definitely yeah I didn't want to keep
that outside now everyone's waiting on
me so I'm kind of lagging a bit
but everything as you can see is outside
it is completely
dark now but everything I have outside
should be fine it's only going to be
there for one day and then we're gonna
get our sick ass garage put in and I am
so freaking excited
just got a text
Christina
that she drafted up an offer
so
that means that tomorrow
will be submitting our offer on our
first rental
and this will be the first of many steps
to our little bear family
um growing our little Financial
portfolio
so that we can get stronger and stronger
and be more well established
and this is definitely one part of
investing in finances that I'm very very
excited about because as you guys know
we were pretty big in crypto
um
pretty decent in stocks too because we
have like a pretty strong retirement
account so real estate is kind of like
that third Frontier that we really
wanted to get into and uh this whole
a year pretty much I've been diving
really really deep
and I've been listening to Bigger
Pockets a lot of you guys probably
listened to it too
um and I listen to them like religiously
and there's so much information on it
about like how to put together like
financing for homes
um how to look for homes how to look for
deals whether you're Airbnb short-term
rental long-term rental multi-family all
that stuff and shout outs to all the
peeps like thatch and everyone out there
that's like putting me on the right
track and has always been I have had a
open door policy with me when I've had
questions because I have a lot of
questions I have a lot of questions I
like to learn you know so I always like
to learn and I I always like to dissect
things and try to understand things in
the way that I need to so
that's tight so pretty cool that uh
we're gonna submit our first offer
tomorrow and I'll let you guys know how
it is and it's cool to take you guys
along this journey as we continue to
progress in in our age and do more and
more more and more grown-up stuff
and uh
it's really cool to really share this
journey with you guys good night